souvenir d'une journée sombre souvenir
d'une semaine où tout a changé
nous nous remémorons enfin l'indignation
qu'a suscitée la profanation de ce lieu
sacré qu'ils aient vécu de près ou de
loin les évènements
ils sont venus par centaines comme si
c'était hier
pour plusieurs difficile de se défaire
de cette épreuve on a travaillé ensemble
soutient qu'un ça va pas être facile
non parce que ça nous rappelle certains
de mémoire que des fois on compterait
pas se souvenait mais on veut président
liés non plus je trouve ça beau de voir
que malgré la tragédie que c'est parti
un an passé tout le monde se rassemble
puis tout le monde se tient solide de
temps pas pourquoi ça fait 1-1 d'autres
c'est important de démontrer un petit
peu de courage aussi pour les gens qui
ont subi ce sort une foule de canadien
anonyme des dignitaires et surtout un
moment unique
la façon dont vous et réagit en
d'immenses qui vous êtes sur qui nous
sommes
pour les proches des disparus une
journée difficile
un pas de plus dans un long parcours
comme pour les soeurs de l'adjudant
patrice vincent c'est une étape mais le
problème de toute la situation c'est que
c'est plus qu'un deuil
à chaque fois que l'on parle de
djihadistes qu'on parle de
radicalisation qu'on parle d'eux
état islamique et
ça nous amène l'eau on est ici parce
relevé faut continuer faut montrer que
garde si au canada c'est comme ça qu'on
vient liberté faut compter si bien des
choses ont changé depuis un an sur le
plan législatif et les contrôles de
sécurité
la douleur et la tristesse elle demeure
la solidarité aussi ici marc godbout
radio canada ottawa